والينا في الاستوديو العميد الياس حنا
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك
العمليات حنا يعني اليوم في العاصمه
انفجارات واسعه هجوم واسع بالمسيرات
صواريخ كروز صواريخ بلاستيه ما تقييمك
لمقامت بها القوات الروسيه اليوم حيال
العاصمه هذا امر طبيعي
استباقا للهجوم الاوكراني المرتقب ايضا
توقيت زياره الرئيس الينسكي الى اربع دول
اوروبيه والاتيان بمساعدات عسكريه مهمه
جدا خاصه من المانيا فاذا هذا ارتباط
بالاضافه الى ان الاسبوع الفائت
اسقط صاروخ كنجال اذا تاكدت المعلومات
بواسطه الباتريوت اليوم هناك يبدو ان هناك
تكتيك جديد من قبل روسيا استعمال عده
صواريخ اسكندر كنجال وبالتالي فقط لاغراق
منظومه الباتريوت لانه
اسقاط الكنجال شيء خطير بالنسبه للرئيس
بوتين بالعام 2018 اعتبر ان الكنجال سيخرج
كل الدفاعات الجويه الامريكيه فماذا لو
كان يحمل راسا نوويا هذا الامر يتبين من
خلال الاستعمال باوكرانيا ان هذا الامر
ليس صحيح
تكتيك جديد كما وصفته هل يمكن اعتباره
بمثابه نقطه تحول عسكريه من قبل موسكو في
سياق هذه الحرب اذا صح هذا الامر هو
التكتيك جديد قد يغير ولكن اذا صح كما
قالت اوكرانيا انها اسقطت فعلا كل
الصواريخ والمسيرات عددها 18 هذا امر يدل
ان الدفاعات الجويه الاوكرانيه وصلت الى
درجه ودرجه متقدمه من عده مستويات هي
قادره على حمايه اوكرانيا خاصه اذا حصل ما
سيحصل في المستقبل الهجوم المرتقب والذي
تحدث عنه وقال لدينا او نريد بعض الوقت
لاستكمال المنظومه لكن بالنظر الى ما قيل
بانه تم استهداف الامدادات الغربيه
برايك ما التاثير الذي يمكن ان تتركه ضربه
روسيه كهذه على
القوات الاوكرانيه العسكريا ضرب المنظومه
اللوجستيه جدا لانها تحرم الجيش الاوكراني
من السلاح الغربي ولكن يبدو ان السلاح
الغربي يدخل 230 دبابه ايمان ادخلت ما
يقارب تسعه الويه دربت في الغرب يوم الكل
يعتمد على الصواريخ على المنظومه
اللوجستيه مؤخرا بريطانيا زودت بستور
مشادو وهو كروز صاروخ كروز او مجنع مسافته
250 كيلومتر فلنتامل كيف اصبحت اوكرانيا
قادره على ضرب عمق وخلفيه الجيش الروسي
خاصه
النقاط اللوجستيه والقياده والسيطره نحن
في مرحله ضبابيه يتبين هذا الامر اعتقد
انه بعد اسبوعين او ثلاثه
اي تكهنات بما يمكن ان تكون عليه الخطوه
الروسيه المقبله الخطوه الروسيه المقبله
يبدو ان هناك مواقع دفاع روسيه
ارتباط يعني ارتباقا للهجوم الاوكراني
ويبدو انه ما تحققه اوكر اليوم في مخموديه
مكاسب معينه ولكن انتقلت روسيه من موقع
الهجوم على الجبهه ككل الى موقع الدفاع
انتظارا لهذا الهجوم المرتقى
واستهداف انظمه الدفاع
الامريكيه في كييف هو بالتالي يعني تنفيذ
لتهديدات موسكو باستهداف مثل هذه الانظمه
لكن كيف يمكن ان يؤثر على المعركه يؤثر
على المعركه يمنع
الكلاب واوكرانيا من الحمايه الجويه واذا
حرمت اوكرانيا من الحمايه الجويه السلاح
الجوي الروسي لا يزال انتكت كما يقال فاذا
هو قادر على منع اي هجوم مرتقب لانه تصبح
القوات الاوكرانيه على ارض الواقع معرضه
لاي هجوم جوي
شكرا جزيلا لك العميد الياس حنا الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجي